Every video game should be awesome, but...we
know that’s not the case.
So, we’ll usually just settle for video
games at least being functional.
Unfortunately, many video games ship with
glitches that make them impassable, or just
outright ridiculous.
Here are a few bugs that destroyed perfectly
good games, and should have sent their programmers
looking for new work.
Ducked up
It's a simple game about hunting delicious
birds for sport, but even Nintendo’s Duck
Hunt was published with a game-breaking glitch.
If you can endure your snickering dog for
99 levels of bird-murdering fun, that's it.
There's nothing there.
Your reward is "Round 0," a foul purgatory
where immortal birds disappear and reappear
at random.
The game ends, proving that there's no reward
for duck genocide, in real life or in Nintendo.
Now for the real challenge: loading those
thousands of duck corpses into your pickup
truck.
The missing Pokemon
In the olden days, there were only 151 Pokémon,
and that was good enough.
Because of programming limitations, the original
Game Boy games left spots for 256 different
encounters in Pokémon Red and Blue.
151 slots were filled with Pokémon, others
with trainers, and 39 spots were left empty.
If you follow a specific sequence of actions,
you'll encounter the mess of code called "MissingNo"
and be able to capture it.
But doing so can cause game-breaking errors
in other parts of your save.
Sometimes, you shouldn't catch 'em all.
Crappy holidays
Back in the day, Sony's video game magazine,
PlayStation Underground, would regularly send
out preview discs to their subscribers, but
around Christmas of 2004, PlayStation 2 owners
were in for a pretty terrible surprise.
Unfortunately, the PlayStation Underground
Holiday 2004 Demo disc would destroy the save
data on any memory card still plugged into
its system, regardless of the game.
Sony sent out warnings, but it was too late.
“Stop, don’t, come back”
Gamers lost thousands of hours of playtime
data when their memory cards were blanked
out.
For many players, those hours had been invested
in the recently-shipped Grand Theft Auto:
San Andreas.
Just think of all those un-murdered civilians.
Boss loss
Bubble Bobble Revolution on the Nintendo DS
includes one of the dumbest bugs ever released.
What should have been a simple remake of a
hundred-level game was accidentally cut short
at Level 30, for no other reason than the
programmers forgot to put in a boss.
Because the boss battle was an essential trigger
to move on to Level 31, the game was simply
unbeatable.
Codemasters eventually replaced the bugged
carts, but they’ll never live down the unmitigated
duncery of their mistake.
Object overload
The massive glitch found in The Elder Scrolls
4: Shivering Isles is also pretty simple:
if you play too much of this Oblivion expansion,
your game will crash.
Because of a programming issue, the PC version
of the expansion would freeze once its memory
was full of background data.
This was because that data wasn’t being
recycled when it was no longer in use.
Bethesda pushed out a fix after about a month,
and the irony that a game expansion called
Shivering Isles had severe freezing issues
was lost on no one.
Don't change a thing
The SoulCalibur series includes a pretty solid
string of fighting games, but a terrible bug
in the third installment nearly derailed the
whole thing for PlayStation 2 users.
The error doesn't manifest as part of the
game itself, but rather when players attempt
to change, move, copy, or delete any of their
older save data associated with any their
games.
The glitch can potentially destroy or corrupt
all of the data on a player's memory card.
While gamers have been able to figure out
workarounds, like saving on a separate memory
card for just this one game, no amount of
jiggle physics is worth losing all of your
games.
Infinitely easy
Players may furiously debate whether or not
the introduction of "infinite spin" to Tetris
Worlds was a glitch or not, but it's game-breaking
enough to be considered a travesty either
way.
By repeatedly hitting the "spin" button, a
player can keep a Tetris piece in the air
indefinitely, which is a totally cheap move.
The official Tetris company unconvincingly
denies that the inclusion of this cheater
move is a glitch, but the easy spin was made
optional in subsequent games.
But still, it’s not the worst thing to ever
happen to Tetris.
That credit goes to appearing in Pixels.
No signal
Batman already has it tough enough, but in
Batman: Dark Tomorrow, he’s pretty much
doomed from the start.
The only way to really beat villain R'as al
Ghul is to find a signal device hidden somewhere…
Except the game never tells you where it is,
or that it even exists.
While it's one of the most Kafkaesque video
game twists of all time, no one plays video
games to feel like a giant, helpless bug.
And making a game with no direction about
how to actually win is a pretty big bug, indeed.
Faceoff
Ubisoft should've taken its time to give Assassin's
Creed Unity a proper debut as the first next-gen
exclusive of the series.
Instead, it was rushed out the door with a
plethora of glitches, clipping issues, and
animation hiccups, which is a bad look considering
the countless number of Assassin's Creed titles
before it.
Even after the patches, Unity still has more
bugs than the courtesans of Paris.
The worst offense?
A glitch during cutscenes that caused faces
to disappear, resulting in a horrifying, grotesque
visage of hair, eyeballs, teeth, and gums
floating above characters' clothes.
We hope someone at Ubisoft got the guillotine
for deciding to ship this ugly, unfinished
product.
Every part of Superman 64
When a game starts out by covering everything
in a "Kryptonite fog" because it can't render
its own graphics, you know you're off to a
bad start.
Regarded as one of the worst games of all
time, Superman: The New Adventures found an
audience among small, stupid children, but
is so full of game-crushing glitches that
it's considered unplayable.
Here’s the catch, though: The whole game
takes place in a virtual reality programmed
by Lex Luthor, so maybe Lex is just a really,
really terrible programmer.
From that perspective, this is actually the
most clever game of all time.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
video game bugs drove you crazy...